kaum ein anderes religiöses oberhaupt
erreicht so viele menschen weltweit und
über die religionsgrenzen hinweg wie tenzin
gyatso die oberste autorität der tibetischen
buddhisten sein anliegen ist es die erreichung
des glücks durch vervollkommnung des geistes
für den einzelnen wie für die menschheit wie er
das erreichen will darüber spreche ich jetzt mit
seiner heiligkeit eine sternstunde religion ihre
heiligkeit ich heiße sie herzlich willkommen zu
unserer sendung es ist eine ehre hier bei uns zu
haben danke das ist auch mir eine ehre sie sind
ein unermüdlicher verfechter des dialogs nicht nur
des dialogs zwischen den religionen sondern auch
zwischen politik wissenschaft und spiritualität
speciality meist auf ich arbeite als muslimin seit
20 jahren im interreligiösen dialog dabei kommt
immer wieder eine bestimmte frage auf was raised
frequently wenn menschen ihren reden zuhören oder
ihre bücher lesen sind diese menschen bereiten
offen für den dialog doch wie erreichen sie die
menschen welche nicht bereit oder nicht die alu
billig sind weil wir alle menschliche wesen
sind haben wir auch die fähigkeit nachzudenken
sie sind wir alle haben die fähigkeit die
dinge ganzheitlich zu betrachten nicht nur
aus kurzfristigem sondern auch aus langfristigem
interesse und neutronen schottland am inn fest
normalerweise und besonders dann wenn
sich emotionen entwickeln dann nutzen
die menschen ihre fähigkeit nicht die
realität ganzheitlich wahrzunehmen
die menschen nutzen dieses potenzial nicht immer
und dann tendieren sie zur kurzsichtigkeit was
ihnen es scheint unmittelbar eine gewisse
befriedigung bringt indem sie die anderen
kritisieren ihnen schaden oder im schlimmsten
fall sogar töten bereitet dass diese menschen
befriedigung das ist kurzsichtig längerfristig
gesehen ist niemand daran interessiert
ich glaube dass die menschliche natur
grundsätzlich mitfühlender ist zudem haben
wir unser wunderbares gehirn durch erziehung
durch bewusst sein können sich diese menschen
ändern sie können lernen die dinge nicht mehr nur
unmittelbar zu betrachten sondern weitsichtiger
es ist bei jedem problem so wenn wir es aus der
nähe betrachten scheint es unerträglich zu sein
aber wenn wir dasselbe problem aus der distanz
betrachten dann sehen wir das ist zwar immer noch
bedauerlich ist aber es ist auf die letzten
jahrzehnte zurück schauen sind die menschen
allgemein nur für den dialog geworden oder eher
verschlossener ich habe folgende erfahrung gemacht
ich denke das interesse am interreligiösen dialog
ist in den letzten zehn jahren stark gewachsen
wohin ich auch gehen auch an interreligiösen
konferenzen stelle ich das immer wieder fest
von dieser interreligiöse dialog
ist nicht nur eine oberflächliche
angelegenheit den menschen ist es ernst
was auch immer der vorherrschende glaube
ist jede große religiösen tradition hat dieselbe
botschaft dieselbe praxis und das ist die praxis
mit dieser praxis geht die praxis der
toleranz oder tiger vergebung einher
philosophisch betrachtet gibt
es verschiedene konzepte doch
wir müssen uns fragen was die absicht der
verschiedenen philosophien ist alle haben
dieselbe absicht sie sind überzeugt vom
wert der liebe vom wert des mitgefühls
bleiben wir noch ein wenig bei den
verschiedenen philosophien und praktiken
wir erleben dass der buddhismus in europa
sehr attraktiv geworden ist es gibt sogar
unternehmen welche buddhistische weisheit und
praktiken zumindest teilweise adaptieren wie
denken sie darüber der buddhismus
gehört traditionsgemäß zum osten
die menschen sind verschieden und haben
auch verschiedene religiöse glauben die
westen herrscht vor allem die jüdisch-christliche
tradition vor in gewissen gebieten auch der islam
es ist sicher wenn jeder bei seinem
eigenen religiösen glauben bleibt
wenn man die religion wechselt führt es
manchmal zu verwirrungen von confusion
es ist also besser die eigene religion zu behalten
es gibt millionen von menschen die aus
irgendwelchen gründen nicht gläubig sind
gehören keiner bestimmten glaubensrichtung
altenfeld aber gleichzeitig möchten sie
eine gewisse art spiritualität erfahren
gewisse geistes übungen praktiziert solche
menschen zeigen sich dann offen für den
buddhismus oder für andere religionen aus
der indischen tradition verglichen etwa für
den sein ismus den buddhismus und hinduismus
das ist deren gutes recht aber wichtig dabei
ist wenn sich menschen neuen religionen
zu wenden etwa dem buddhismus hinduismus
oder zynismus und welche ihnen persönlich
mehr behagen so bedeutet das nicht dass ihre
ursprüngliche traditionelle religion wertlos
deshalb müssen diese menschen ihren
ursprünglichen glauben respektieren das ist
sehr wichtig weil ich sie richtig verstanden
habe dann sind die skeptisch wenn hier leute
von sich behaupten sie seien christliche
buddhisten oder buddhistische christen
möglicherweise bedeutet als christ glaubt man
an den schöpfer an jesus christus oder an die
dreifaltigkeit aber gleichzeitig muss man als
buddhist auch den buddhistischen glauben buddha
respektieren das ist schwierig aber auf dieser
ebene kann man das vielleicht kombinieren es
gibt menschen die finden diese haltung
würde ihnen mehr inneren frieden bringen
einverstanden aber denn wenn man dann aber
eine tiefere ebenen erreicht dann kommt das
buddhistische konzept der lehrzeit zum
tragen dort gibt es keinen platz mehr
für einen unabhängigen absoluten schöpfer
independent absolut trete ich verstehe warum
ich glaube es ist schon über zehn jahre
her damals habe ich mit einem guten freund
einen amerikanischen christlichen münch ein
wunderbarer mensch diskutiert wir haben oft
miteinander diskutiert über die praktiken
seiner religion wie etwa mitleid vergebung
toleranz er war sehr interessiert und wollte
etwas lernen über die indische tradition die
einzelnen punkte der meditation beide wollten von
der anderen tradition mehr erfahren das haben wir
gemacht haben über solche dinge diskutiert
einmal fragte er mich wieder begriff der
lehrzeit im buddhismus zu verstehen sei ich
antwortete ihm fragt mich nicht solche sachen
die lehrzeit gehört zum geschäft des
buddhisten nicht des christmas sie
wollen dieses konzept nicht teilen denn ein
glaubenssatz des buddhismus lautet es gibt
nichts das losgelöst existiert one or nothing
independent ex ist im buddhismus zynismus und
in anderen altindischen religionen allgemein
in der buddhistischen glaubens gemeinschaft
gibt es das konzept des schöpfers nicht ich
wollte nicht dass mein freund sich mit dieser
sichtweise vertraut macht denn er glaubt an
einen schärfer an gott diese sichtweise könnte
eine negative wirkung auf ihn haben das möchte
ich nicht es ist besser wenn jeder bei seiner
tradition bleibt sie in front deshalb denken
sie ist der buddhismus für europa so attraktiv
ich denke der buddhismus allgemein
insbesondere aber der buddhismus in
der nordindischen tradition oder selbst legte
fest und rät uns dort praktizierte meine lehre
nicht einfach blind nur durch glaube und hingabe
sondern fortan 8 und mache experimente das hat
oder aufgetragen in der nordindischen tradition
der salz crypt radiation wendet man reichlich
logische untersuchungen und experimente es gibt
leute die eher wissenschaftlich denken und die
vernunft lieben wie der vorletzte papst den ich
dem deutschen papst zu nennen pflegen sich er
sagte glaube und vernunft müssen zusammen gehen
solche menschen welche eine wissenschaftliche
denkweise haben oder die vernunft lieben werden
gewisse ideen nicht einfach durch glauben annehmen
ich denke dass für solche menschen
die buddhistische vorgehensweise
anziehend ist also verstand
und experiment zu gebrauchen
menschen aus dem westen die am buddhismus
interessiert sind lieben wenn ich das so
sagen darf den blinden glauben nur
die praxis ohne innere überzeugung
ohne zu denken nur glauben das
ist ungesund das ist nicht gut
lassen sie uns zu einem weiteren thema kommen
die buddhistische islamischen beziehungen ist
der samsung gibt es zurzeit einen buddhistisch
islamischen dialog wurde ist islamisch bei lok
ist nicht besonders rege aber in ladakh in
nordindien schon traditionsgemäß besteht
dort eine enge beziehung zwischen den buddhisten
und den muslimen schon seit vielen jahren pflege
ich enge beziehungen zur muslimischen brüdern und
schwestern sowohl zu schiiten als auch zu mieten
erst vor kurzem war ich in ladakh auf einer
pilgerreise am gleichen tag habe ich zuerst
die buddhistischen tempel besucht und dann
den sunnitischen tempel die sunnitische
moschee und dann die schiitische moschee
das alles am gleichen tag am gleichen morgen
die us liebe gehören zu einer der wichtigsten
weltreligion sie sind anhänger des islam des
koran der islam ist eine sehr wichtige
religion viele muslime sind wunderbare
menschen es gibt auch bösartige menschen
wie sie jede religionsgemeinschaft wie
sie auch der buddhismus hat der hinduismus
hat das christentum oder das judentum oder
wer auch immer bösartiger menschen gibt es
überall diese wenigen bösartigen menschen
repräsentieren niemals die ganze tradition
wir müssen diese unterscheidung macht
heutzutage etwas passiert heißt es
gewöhnlich die muslime sind terroristen
oder wenn etwas in burma passiert dann heißt
es die buddhisten sind terroristen so es ist
völlig falsch muslim den war muslime oder
wahre buddhisten fügen anderen menschen
niemals leicht zu der muslim ist nach dem islam
dem koran muss jeder der den islam praktiziert
jeder praktizierende muslime freut die rechte
der anderen respektieren klärten brachat und
in dem moment wo er blut vergießt ist er in
wirklichkeit kein praktizierender gläubiger
muslim im eigentlichen sinne mir einer meiner
muslimischen freunde sagte muir wer den islam
praktiziert muss liebe verbreiten und
zwar gegenüber der gesamten schöpfung
ich bin einverstanden dennoch möchte
ich zwei ereignisse diskutieren die
die buddhistische islamischen beziehungen
mit geformt haben dürften dass eine liegt
15 jahre zurück als die taliban die buddha
statuen im afghanischen bamiyan tal zerstört
haben alle in afghanistan wie hat dieser
barbarische akt symbolistisch islamischen
beziehungen beeinflusst zu jener zeit wurde
ich von einigen buddhisten aus verschiedenen
buddhistischen ländern kritisiert weil
ich zu diesem ereignis geschwiegen haben
ich denke vergangenheit ist vergangenheit
heute ist das kein buddhistisches gebiet mehr
buddha statuen waren für die einheimischen
offenbar nicht so bedeutend das ist meine
meinung das ist bemerkenswert wirft man
einen blick auf die geschichte dann hat
es immer schon solche zerstörungen und
verwüstungen durch muslime gegeben wie
etwa in landau ich denke auch dass vieles
to pass durch muslime zerstört wurden
vergangenheit ist vergangenheit immer das
gleiche zu wiederholen hat keinen wert der
vergangenheit ist vergangenheit schreiten wir
zu gegenwart die haben eben auch puma erwähnt
von der situation im januar weiß man dass die
muslimische minderheit die rohingya verfolgt
werden der führenden politischen figur und
chefdiplomatin angst anzuziehen die wie sie
trägerin des friedensnobelpreises ist wird
vorgeworfen dass sie zu den vorkommnissen
schweigt was ist ihre haltung dazu ein
übergriff als die nachricht um die welt
ging das buddhistische mönche gewaltsam gegen die
muslimische minderheit vorgehen war ich in medien
leute wollten meine meinung dazu erfahren ich war
sehr traurig und sagte jene buddhisten sollten
sich mal wo das gesicht vorstellen mit genau
in jenem moment das fest denn bei ihnen diese
negativen gefühle hochkommen genau dann sollten
sie sich bout das gesicht vor augen führen und das
psn buddha kommen würde würde er definitiv jene
muslimischen brüder und schwestern beschützen
das ist eine sehr traurige geschichte danach hatte
ich ein paar mal die gelegenheit mich
mit aung san suu kyi zu treffen bei
den treffen der nobelpreisträger aus
einem mal traf ich sie kurz in london
ich habe ihr gesagt sie müsse
etwas dagegen unternehmen
daraufhin sagte sie das sei sehr kompliziert
das militär sei dafür zuständig und es sei
selber darin verwickelt sein kann es ist ich
meinerseits habe an sie appelliert aber sie
fand es schwierig ich habe keine beziehung und
zu boden ich war noch nie da ein überwinden was
uns hier in europa erstaunt sie ihre heiligkeit
lehnen gewalt strikte ab mailand was wir aber
da sehen ist gewalt ausgehend von buddhistischen
mönchen das erstaunt uns weil der buddhismus das
image einer gewaltlosen religion hat das habe ich
vorher schon erwähnt buddhisten die sich muench
gewänder anziehen und gewalt anwenden sind keine
waren polizisten das gilt auch für muslime von
denen sie sagen diejenigen die verbrechen begehen
stehen außerhalb ja jene die gewalt anwenden und
terroristen sind es sind keine waren buddhisten
oder muslime gut lassen sie uns auf unserer
gesellschaft hier zurückkommen für den mann ist
nicht buddhisten nur weil man dieses gewand trägt
einmal war ich in mexiko dort wurde
ich von katholiken in eine katholische
universität eingeladen als ich da an
kam waren viele bischöfe anwesend ich
sagte ihnen manchmal scheint es als ob
er uns geistlichen unser glaube an der
kleidung so lange wird diese kleider an
haben hält man uns für heilige menschen
wenn wir unsere kleider oder gewänder
ausziehen dann sind wir keine richtigen
gläubigen aber manche bischöfe und andere
priester bekommen solche kommentare oft zu
hören ließ religion ist eine geistige haltung
und hat nichts zu tun mit einem körperlichen
erscheinungsbild von rebellenchef
ein buddhistin eine mönchsgewand der
im geist böse und gewalttätig ist oder
gar tötet ist kein wahrer buddhist mehr
empfinden ihre heiligkeit je wut gelegentlich
begegnet sie ihrer mut zum beispiel meine
mitarbeiter ganz kleine fehler machen
das dauert aber du ein paar
sekunden dann ist es wieder vorbei
wir haben über die wut gesprochen und sind
schon fast am schluss aber lassen sie uns
erst noch über ein anderes gefühl sprechen
eines das vielleicht so gut führen kann
unser gesellschaftlich zurzeit stark bestimmt
durch das gefühl von angst besonders groß ist
die angst bei uns in europa unsere kulturelle
identität zu verlieren durch emigration und
globalisierung wie denken sie darüber als jemand
der selbst die erfahrung von flucht und leben im
exil kennt gleichzeitig kämpft auch ihr folgen
seine kulturelle und religiöse identität sie
bringen also beide perspektiven mit was sagen
sie menschen hier welche um den verlust ihrer
kulturellen identität führt zurzeit kommen viele
flüchtlinge aus afrikanischen arabischen gebieten
ich schätze es dass man in europa so viele
flüchtlinge aufnimmt und ihnen schutz und
unterschlupf gewährte dem shirt es ist wunderbar
vor allem die deutsche kanzlerin
sie zeigt wirklich menschlichkeit
gleichzeitig finde ich und das habe ich auch
schon vorher in einem anderen zusammenhang erwähnt
wenn die eu aber tausende oder millionen von
flüchtlingen aufnimmt sollte sie ihnen auch schutz
gewährte den kindern und muss
sie den zugang zur bildung
ermöglichen in jungen menschen eine ausbildung
man sollte nicht vergessen dass
diese menschen mit der zeit in
ihre heimat zurückkehren und
ihre heimat wieder aufbauen
dann sollten die länder die die flüchtlinge
aufnehme ihnen auch nach der rückkehr in deren
heimat weiterhelfen kann die newslettern sie
nahtlos auch dort beim wiederaufbau unterstützen
mich so wie ihnen wenn nötig auch kapital
beschaffen dies empfand es können nicht alle
menschen aus dem arabischen raum hierher
kommen sonst sind ihre länder entvölkern
es können nur ein paar wenige kann
in den arabischen ländern gibt es
ein großes potenzial es lasst sie aufbauen bild
sie konnten bisher nicht in ihre
heimat zurückkehren wenn ich sie
nun bitte eine vorausschau zu machen die
denken sie wie wir die welt in 50 jahren
1996 hatte ich gelegenheit die
mutter der queen zu treffen
sie war damals 96 jahre alt sie hat also
fast ein ganzes jahrhundert miterlebt ich
fragte sie was denken sie werden die
welt und die menschheit besser bleiben
sie gleich oder werden sie schlecht ohne
zu zögern antwortete sie besser sie fügte
ein beispiel an als sie jung war sprach
noch niemand über menschenrechte oder
das recht auf selbstbestimmung heute
sind solche themen allgemeingültig
letzten jahrhunderts hauptsächlich zu beginn
des letzten jahrhunderts waren die menschen
ihm vor allem die wissenschaftler
begeistert nuklearwaffen herzustellen
im letzteren teil des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts ist immer mehr darüber
gesprochen worden wie man dieser waffen abrüsten
in den letzten jahren hat obama sogar davon
gesprochen diese waffen zu verbieten und
die welt atomwaffenfrei zu machen das sind
positive zeichen auch für die totalitären
systeme der gedanke ohne waffen hat zu
einer veränderung der denkweise gefahr
weil die eigenen bewohner sich geändert haben
ist die damalige sowjetunion zusammengebrochen
ist ihnen viele osteuropäische länder sind
heute freie länder china was mehr nordkorea
weniger nun auch china hat sich schon
stark verändert es ist zwar immer noch
kommunistisch und hat dieselbe verfassen
aber die realität hat sich sehr verändert
es ist zeichen der veränderung verdeutlicht
folgendes beispiel in china gibt es heute
etwa 400 millionen buddhisten damals während der
kulturrevolution wurde jeder glaube vorsätzlich
zerstört dies muss hat aber überlegt heute gibt
es in china wie vorher bereits erwähnt etwa 400
millionen buddhisten und wohl etwas weniger als
200 millionen christen das sind große veränderung
wie optimistisch ich glaube an die
menschheit die letzten jahre gab es
immer wieder treffen von wissenschaftlern
dass wissenschaftler vorher untersucht
haben wird nun bestätigt die menschen
sind heute grundsätzlich mitfühlender
hessische minister ist more compassion das
ist einfach nachzuvollziehen die ständige
angst ich lerne ständige zorn frist unser
ganzes immunsystem auf kassel immunsystem
komplett meint mehr mitgefühl mehr frieden
hilft uns unsere gesundheit zu behalten dew
münchen gut hält wenn jemand wirklich
von wert des mitgefühls überzeugt ist
dann hilft das allen religionen diese
inneren werte aufrecht zu erhalten
ihre heiligkeit wir sind bereits
am ende ich danke ihnen dafür dass
ihr wissen und ihre weisheit mit uns geteilt haben